i love this guy he is the head coach of
the world champion tampa bay buccaneers
kicking off hour number two of the rich
eisen show here on this first wednesday
in june 2021 he is bruce arians how are
you coach arians
i'm outstanding rich and uh of course
i'd be early for you brother i
appreciate that
greatly what is going on in your world
these days you've got
uh uh a mandatory mini camp that starts
monday what what is going on in your
world right now
bruce yeah we've got we've got about 45
young guys that we've been working with
through otas and um
two weeks of boutiques with those guys
and getting their feet wet and giving
them opportunity to show off in front of
the coaches without
without the veterans and bring all the
rest of the guys in next week and kick
off uh what is
our journey for next year well there's
been a lot of conversation specifically
with your team about who's showing up
who's not who's there who wants to be
there
but isn't going to be there because of
whatever is going on with the players
association in the nfl
writ large what has been your approach
to uh
your veteran players who you want to be
there but
may not want to be there um and uh
what what has been your approach this
non-playing season
2021 yeah basically rich what i told the
28
31 guys that played the most time last
year
you know 80 of the time i don't need you
um
don't need you here i need you in shape
need to do all your zone meetings
and refresh your you know get go look at
all the mistakes and stuff but i will
need you here
physically um until min mini camp
and uh the rest of the guys i want all
we've missed three years of young player
development you know with the pandemic
last year's rookies the year before guys
didn't make it in so
we need this rookie development time and
young player development time so
if you're a new player here or or if you
didn't play
if you're on a practice squad or 20 or
less last year you're here practicing
and so uh however you did give the
facility
over to brady and other veterans to work
out there but no coaches there
right that happened kind of leased it
yeah they were throwing
they were throwing over they were
throwing over yankee stadium and you
know we've got three fields here
and i got you know i talked to them look
guys you
you're you do what you want to do over
here
and if one of you get hurt you're
covered
all right i don't want to happen at
juwan james or hamilton to happen to
denver
guys getting hurt off-site and uh so
you know bring them over here throw over
here
now it's different that's a phase two
day where we can do that an ota day
there's different
rules as far as how much time we're
allowed on the field
so um they'll do that again this week
and then we'll kick it off next week
so basically like last year uh when the
pandemic was full
rage um and or just
first blush that was it was new to
everybody
uh and brady was working out with some
of the players in a
like a local park he upgraded to the
yankee
stadium facility there in tampa and
you're like hey we got our own spot here
just
come on in and you do what you want to
do and
nobody was there from team coaching like
you didn't have like a
no no i was actually i was actually i
left town i went to the lake
okay so i should say like yeah there's
no like hiding spot where you were
behind like a tackle
i told our coaches i don't want anybody
out there and uh
i literally was out of town and uh so
they had i had i heard they had a really
good workout and uh
you know tom checks in every week and um
so uh it's been it's been a really good
offseason for those guys
a little more concerned about our
defensive backs because they're not
doing what
the offensive receivers and quarterbacks
are doing okay well we'll get to that in
a second i got bruce arians here on the
rich eisen show
when you say tom checks in every week
what do you what do you mean what
what what can you reveal about that
well how how's he feeling biggest thing
is how's the knee
um he's not he doesn't have a golf game
right now so it's not about his golf
game but it's just
you know checking in on him how he's
feeling what he's doing
what his plan was for the week and who
he you know we got mike evans was in
this week and
a few other guys so um yeah i'm always
in touch with him
is that by text by zoom by what
phone calls mostly by text text text
facetime time like to facetime
i'm not a facetimer
no why aren't you a face timer i thought
i mean your grandfather right
i do that with i do my yeah i do that
with my grandkids called portals
i do that all the time okay all right
but yeah i mean but you know i know
tom's not old enough to be your
grandchild
but i mean like but he's kind of like
one of your most important football kids
in a way bruce right oh yeah definitely
okay
yeah actually a funny story rich my son
jake yep
and tom went to combine together
kicker that year back in 2000
yeah well who's the kicker for uab and
ended up kicking for atlanta and buffalo
so
before he got hurt whose kanban photo is
more impressive then
my mind by far
okay just want to check on that okay so
how how is brady
feeling like how much you think he's
going to be able to do next year great
yeah
yeah i had i got to see that myself and
talk to the doctors but uh
i don't think i'm let anybody chase him
around um hopefully i do 707 and some
other stuff
and just see how he feels okay because i
did see a quote that you say he'll do
more coaching what do you mean by that
yeah what would you mean he's gonna get
every you get he'll get every rep
mentally
and uh sometimes if you're standing back
there coaching whoever's in there
you're getting just as much out of it as
he is without doing the physical work
did you have a conversation with tom
before the draft about uh because
we i i spoke to jason light about this
and again i'm so fascinated by
relationships with coaches and goat
quarterbacks as you know
there's uh you know from front office
and goat quarterbacks as you know
there's there's something going on in
the state of wisconsin these days
uh did you have a chat with tom before
the draft about uh
possibly drafting somebody uh at his
position
oh yeah yeah we talked about the whole
thing you know what we what we're
thinking and
you know he's he's so super interested
in all that stuff too so
i mean yeah we had number of
conversations and as we got closer and
closer
you know you know say hey check this guy
out check this guy out
and see if you like him and uh you know
so it um
yeah we have a great relationship that
way well i mean check which does
i think that's imperative no of course
well check which guy out like
like uh right at for receivers okay look
at look at these receivers and
see if there's something uh that you
like and and i'll i'll critique your
ability to
critique receivers
how'd he do he did great yeah he like
there's certain things he likes he likes
really good big fast guys
you know what so do you right i mean
kind of dovetails at least at least you
guys have similar
similar likes right there and so uh all
right and in
in terms of um with brady and coaching
people up
uh uh when you say coaching uh uh
during the mini camp you just let him
you let him go
let it just be him let him be 12 and and
you just sit back and just
reap the benefits that's yours yeah well
that's what that's what he's doing when
he's practicing anyway whether he's
in there uh somebody else might be
getting a rep and he'll see something
and
and he'll grab the guy especially a
young player that's one thing i didn't
know about tom
not having him uh but once he got here
it's like
he is an unbelievable teammate he and he
really
gravitates to these young guys and tries
to help him on and off the field
bruce aryan's here uh on the rich eisen
show when you said he didn't have a golf
game you you do know he's got one
against aaron rodgers with phil
nicholson against bryson deschambeau you
did pick up on that
right last week did you just i did i did
but i know i know he's not swinging yet
and uh he's gonna he's gonna have to
have a crash he had a bunch of golf
balls before uh
before that thing well that's that's
something of of interest
did you see again bruce i don't know
people might bring it to your attention
i know you are
uh on social media did you see brady go
at rogers um
[Laughter]
see you you did see him say to tell
deshambo better get used to laying up
because we know rogers isn't going for
it did you see that one
bruce i did yes i did okay yes i did
does that get the
comment on that
because that's that's you know he's
looking for the biscuit with that risk
it
right there right oh yeah always baby
yes indeed
i was about to ask if that got the blue
check mark from the coach that sort of
comment
at all yeah that was a good one yeah i
like it okay
so all right so i'm i can't believe i'm
getting bruce bruce erin's golf updates
on tom brady from the head coach but
that is that isn't that is certainly
of of importance okay so now let's get
to the defense what what is your concern
about your
your defense right here top of june
going into next week's
um yeah you know it's easy for it's easy
for a quarterback quarterback to grab
the tight end receivers running backs
and they go start working routes
and concepts and and getting some
details
it's not as easy for dbs to get together
and run through coverages
without anybody to do it against and
you know i think last year during the
pandemic they did do
some stuff like that on their own um
this year they haven't yet but
we'll get a dose of it next week okay
and i i asked this question of pete
carroll the other day and he was like
what are you getting at
um so i gingerly ask you sir um but i'd
have had conversations with you about
how long you want to keep coaching
uh when you left arizona and you
mentioned about um
you know your health concerns and things
of that nature
um what what's your mindset as you enter
this uh
title defense season bruce and how long
you want to keep
doing what you're doing there in tampa
yeah
somebody asked me that the other day
richard it's like you know when i
seriously don't like going to work
uh if i have a feeling that i'm cheating
somebody
i'll give it up but right now i'm having
so much damn fun it's uh
it's hard to even think about it i love
the group of guys i love our staff
and coming to work every day so it's
keeping me young
and the one thing about having a job you
know you're around good doctors all the
time
you are you are there there's no doubt
about it that's
that's a benefit um to the gig and i
know that you
last time you chatted um you and your
wife are gonna celebrate
your golden anniversary um i believe
that's next week right
june 12th that was the last time yeah
june 12th june 12th
it's hard to believe but uh i have a
little party on the
13th we're gonna have the party on
sunday night okay and so your wife
everybody's the team aaron's as i saw
front and center
for your charity event this this season
you're all on board you still coaching
and being there every single day and
and you're everybody's still rowing in
the same direction
on that front right oh definitely
definitely you know jake's my agent and
uh
he's not letting me quit so um but so
it's uh yes
it is it's um if the foundation event
went off
unbelievable i hope it gets bigger and
better next year and uh
now yeah our family is uh we're enjoying
the ride right now
i bet you are and before i let you go
then um
you know leftwitch and todd bowles did
not get
um a head coaching gig based off of
winning
the super bowl um do you think this
could be your last year
having both of them on your your
sideline bruce like what what is what is
your take on
on hiring in the nfl and having those
guys maybe
for just a potentially another year
bruce yeah i think you know rich had the
hiring process been after the super bowl
they both got jobs and for the jobs they
did
and i i wouldn't doubt they would both
have opportunities next year for sure
and uh
you know my job is to have the next guys
ready
uh as the next guy is ready for
coordinators and the next guy's ready to
be
assistant coaches so i love that part of
the process because i know left
leftwitch is your hand-picked play
caller
and you you you you personally
handpicked him right i mean you you kind
of
yeah years ago you went up to him and
said you are coaching
like i don't want to hear it right i
mean like isn't that the story in a way
it took me about it took me about three
years to get him off the couch
but once he got off the couch that hook
went in deep
he's hooked for life right i mean and so
but he is the guy
i know that you you you count on to to
call the plays and be sort of your id
in a way out there on the field calling
plays in real time
and and that's important in a manner to
keep you head coach
i imagine bruce right yeah a bunch
a bunch definitely richard uh you know
let's we'll see what happens uh if that
were to occur
you know whether i would i would i've
got enough capable people here to do it
right um um but you know
i might want to call the plays but not
necessarily be the offensive coordinator
so
we'll see how that all works but uh i
would hate to lose him
but then i'd be really happy for him i i
bet before i let you go bruce
uh you know i kind of you kind of threw
me one of those uh midnight to six
o'clock curveballs on nfl network live
during the draft coverage when i was
interviewing you
um and i i mentioned brady throwing the
lombardi trophy from one boat to the
other
in a uh in the boat parade uh and you
saying that you know
you were the first to do it like
wondering how
the the the trophy got on brady's boat
now that i've got one last crack at this
did you really flip the lombardi trophy
to brady first before he flipped it too
oh you got a camera right you got
you got to remember you remember i was a
wishbone quarterback
okay those were mostly handoff pitches
okay you know i didn't throw it i didn't
throw it
i think my career stats are like one of
tom's games but
not that good okay and passing so it's
more of a
long handoff okay so but it did it might
have got some air it might have got a
little air time
so a little bit so it was it like a
pitch like a
like a like a wishbone wingt pitch did
you is that what it was or
not quite that far okay so there is a
photo like if there was a photograph of
it there is a snapshot
of a moment in time of the lombardi
trophy not being in somebody's hands
based from you sending it to yeah
probably
was it brady who who took it from you is
that who took it from no i think it was
somebody on his boat or somebody on the
boat his boat
okay well i want to give you the credit
i want to give it it's funny i asked
jason
i asked jason liked this uh coach and
his he said his memory was too fuzzy
is what he said he had no details for me
i'm still a little fuzzy myself coach
thanks for the time
uh enjoy the uh mandatory mini camp and
getting your guys
all back together and then at the end of
the week enjoying the the 50th with your
wife
congrats on all that i appreciate it
rich thanks brother let's catch up again
soon
that's bruce arians head coach the tampa
bay buccaneers hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here